This is Jocko podcast number
one 74 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink. Good
Evening Echo. Good evening.
So
I was the commander of
the training detachment,
which runs the tactical kind of advanced
training for the west coast seal teams.
And when I was in that position,
one of the things that you have to do
when you're in a leadership position is
you have to give a valuations
for everyone that works for you.
You have to basically write down and
evaluate how good they are and how well
they do their job.
This is normal for everyone in the navy.
Then everyone in the military really.
And in the navy it's a 5.0 system
that you're getting graded on.
So 5.0 is the best and 1.0 is the worst.
I don't know if even go lower than
that. You probably can, but there,
and there are rules about how many
people you can put at the top.
You have to for, it's called forced
ranking. If you ever heard of that,
forced ranking means you have
to actually rank everyone.
So if you have 10 people working for you,
you have to rank.
This is my number one guy,
this is my number two guy all the way
down through number 10 and this is what
you cannot do is you can't just
say, hey, everyone's great.
Everyone's a 5.0 that's,
that's,
you're not allowed to do that.
And believe it or not,
that's what people would do.
Most people would just have to evaluate
someone. Guess what they say, Hey,
you're great.
You do everything great.
And you wouldn't think that the military,
the military would have a hard
time telling people like, hey,
here's some areas where
you need to improve.
You wouldn't think that the military,
especially like the seal teams,
you're the big tough seal is going to
have a hard time telling some someone,
hey, this is where your
performances could be better. Right?
But actually no one likes
having those hard conversations.
I shouldn't say just about no one
likes having those hard conversations.
And in fact,
this is completely evident in the fact
that there was an old evaluation system
when I first got into the navy and
there you didn't have to force rank,
you could just make everyone
perfect basically on paper.
And that's actually what happened.
That system was a 4.0 system.
So it was a 4.0 was the highest that you
could get and everyone was a 4.0 guy.
Everyone got four point ohs in everything.
And
actually you have to take that back.
And I think I might've
talked about this before,
but my first evaluation
that I got at a seal team,
I wasn't even in a platoon yet,
but I was going through
the initial training that
you used to do to seal team.
When you got to the seal team,
you did something called Stt,
which was stood for seal tactical
training and it basically taught you the,
is a little bit more advanced
skills than you learned in buds.
And I got a 4.0 and everything,
but I actually got a 3.8 in a
category called human relations.
And I was, I guess, you know,
I talked to my friends though,
we got 4.0 and everything and
everyone got four point except for me,
I got the 3.8 and so then you're
supposed to get a counseling right from,
and the officer that had written my,
the officer that had written my evaluation
and giving me all 4.0 4.0 in tactics,
4.0 and that's 4.0 and the other thing.
And then a 3.8 and human relations.
And he had to counsel me cause
that's what you have to do.
You have to go through and
make sure that no one objects.
And he, he looked at me
and he said, you know,
I I give you a 3.8 in,
you know,
in human relations because well because
I think you're a little too hard on
people that are,
that are unsat.
And I kind of took pride
in that, you know, cause I,
at that time I wasn't really
playing the game. You know,
I kinda was thinking to myself, yeah,
Aye Aye. That's right. You know,
if you're UNSAT I am going to be hard
on you and you can probably guess of the
group that I was in,
which individual I was harder on than
any one else who was actually that guy.
So that was kind of funny.
But you know, after that,
after I got into a seal platoon then all,
you know,
everything was 4.0 all the time.
And again,
I'm not bragging at all about
that because every single guy,
we all had 4.0 it crossed the board on
everything and everyone was the best seal
in the seal teams ever in the history
of ever. That's what it was like.
And everyone was this just this, just the
way it was. Everyone was the best soap.
The navy realize this.
Basically the navy realized that all the
leaders were cowards and when it came
to telling the truth to the troops about
where they stood and where they can
improve. So they made, they made a change,
they made this drastic change to the
evaluation and they changed to this thing
called forced ranking where whatever
there was percentages on how many people
could be ranked at the highest level,
like it was like 10% of your people can
be ranked at the highest level and then
20% of the next tier and
went on down the line.
You didn't actually have to rank someone
as bad but you couldn't rank a bunch of
people at the top and
it was,
it actually made a,
made a big difference all of a sudden
because now all of a sudden you had to,
if you were in a leadership position,
you had to give your,
some of your people some lower rankings
when you actually had to figure out who
is better and
eventually what they did is that again,
people not wanting to
have hard conversations.
Eventually what they did is,
because how you advance in the
navy is based on your evaluations,
which is what we're talking about.
But it's also based on how much time
you have in grade. So you can't,
if you make,
if you're an [inaudible],
you can't make a five for three years
or there's some, some random number,
like you cannot make a
five for three years.
And so what they started doing is just
ranking you based on how long you were
there for. And so that's,
that's what they started doing.
So basically it didn't really help
because you still ended up just
saying, oh well you know, you,
you're just new and that's why
you didn't get promoted. Well,
I didn't really understand
that when the first,
when the very first of the forced
ranking evaluations came out,
I had just made e five and because I
had just made e five I got ranked at the
bottom of the fives in my platoon.
And like I said,
at this time I wasn't really
playing the game really fully.
So I was Kinda went to my chief
and my and my lieutenant with,
hey, why am I, why am I
at the bottom? W W how,
how can I be the lowest ranking of
the fives because that's just wrong.
What about this guy here? You know,
one of my, this guy over here,
you're telling me that this guy
is doing a better job than I am.
Cause I was working really hard and
doing a good job and they didn't disagree
with me. What they said. It's like,
look, yes Jocko, you're, you're,
you're definitely doing a better
job than that guy and that guy.
But here's the deal.
They're up for promotion and you're not.
And when you're up for promotion,
you'll be at the top when it's your turn.
And again, I wasn't really playing
the game, so I said, Oh okay,
I get it. Why didn't you just
tell me that were communists?
It was what's going on there. And you
know, there are no, we're not communists.
It's just, you know, this is just the way
that the system work. And I said, okay,
so what you're telling me is this is
the communist system as well as what's
happening.
Thanks comrade.
And of course they did their
best to explain it to me
and I didn't really listen
because like I said, don't, it wasn't
really playing the game at this time.
I was a young, you know,
e five getting after it,
but eventually it was me that was
evaluating people and force ranking them.
And then it was me that was explaining
the rules of why people got ranked,
where they got ranked and why I
gave him the grades that I gave him.
And of course I did this a bunch from
when I was an assistant platoon commander
and a platoon commander and a task unit
commander. So I had done this a bunch of,
now I was the officer in charge of the
training attachment and I had one of the
guys that didn't like where he got
ranked. He, he was, he, he didn't like it.
He thought he deserved higher and he,
he thought he deserved a bunch of five
o's that the highest possible grade and
Oh, you know, maybe not on all
the criteria but on some of them.
And he actually requested
on office call with me,
meaning he wanted to come and talk to me,
which was kind of weird because at this
time people literally would just walk in
my office all the time and say,
Hey, what's up? I got to, you know,
they were talking about something I was
super casual about people coming to see
me. No, no factor. Right.
So when this guy went and actually
organized an official meeting with me,
I was, you know, I was totally
cool with it, but it was weird.
And he came in and he had his evaluation
with them and he put it on my desk and
you know, he said something
along the lines of, you know,
I got ranked in the middle of the pack
and how did this happen and I should be
at the top or, or at least I should
be near it and I should have five o's.
And in this category and that Cody Gillrie
and this other category and the guy
himself, he wasn't a slacker
by any stretch of imagination.
Who was what goods,
really solid seal.
He wasn't like an over the
top outstanding front runner,
but he was really,
really solid,
which you only allowed to have a very
small number of guys that you're ranking
as front runners. And he wasn't
there. And you know, I was,
I was better at this point at
playing the game, you know,
up and down the chain of command.
And so what I did was I sat there and I
listened to them and I listened to his
perspective.
And as I was doing that,
as I was listening this guy and I
was thinking to myself, you know,
this guy's a hardworking seal.
He thinks he should have
higher grades across the board.
He thinks he should be a top
ranked guy with five point ohs.
And as I'm sitting there listening to him,
I'm thinking,
why does he actually think that?
Why does he think that? What?
What is going on in his head that
he thinks that he should be a 5.0
and of course I'm thinking to myself,
this is somehow my fault.
This has gotta be my fault because
I'm the leader and I have a guy,
I have a guy that's concerned enough
about his rankings that he's in here
talking to me. He actually
set an appointment to come
and talk to me about this.
So obviously I have not done a good job
at this point of explaining things to
him. And if I'm, if I'm,
if he doesn't get it,
obviously there's gonna be more
people that, that think the same way,
then you know, he's not the only one
when someone comes to the problem,
they're not the only one. So that's
what I'm thinking and I'm, um,
I'm thinking that he's thinking he's
a 5.0 that's what he's thinking.
He's thinking he's a 5.0
and he's not,
and he thinks he should be.
And then I'm trying to figure out,
I'm thinking to myself,
okay,
how do I explain to him
where he is missing the mark?
How can I explain to him that he's not
quite a 5.0 because 5.0 is outstanding
and then the answer kind
of jumped out at me.
The answer was the evaluation form itself.
That's,
that's what it was because the
evaluation form itself actually gives the
definition of what a 5.0
sailor is what a 5.0 liter is.
And really when you break it down to
what a 5.0 human being is the evaluation
actually spells it out
in plain English.
So I picked up the evaluation form that
he had brought in and I started to read
chunks of it to him.
So the first little chunk
that I read to read to him,
there's a section called
professional knowledge and,
and if you are a 5.0 in
professional knowledge,
it gives you a list of what you are.
And here's what it says.
If you're a five point on professional
knowledge, this is what it says,
recognized expert,
sought out by all for technical knowledge,
uses knowledge to solve
complex technical problems,
meets advancement requirements
early and with distinction.
So you know, I looked at him and
said, okay, recognized expert.
Are you a recognized expert?
Does how often are you getting called
by the east coast or by the seal team to
help them solve a problem? The answer
was he's not. He's a good solid guy,
really good instructor,
but he's not a,
he's not a recognized
expert and he knew it.
And then I read the the 3.0 which
is a middle grade. Like, Hey,
this is your average situation. I said,
maybe this is you. I said, listen,
strong working knowledge
of rating specialty and job
reliably applies knowledge
to accomplish tasks,
meets advancement requirements on time.
This is a solid human being,
right? This is a solid, that's a,
that's a 3.0 right there. And again, as
I'm reading through this, this guy, yeah,
he had strong working knowledge for sure.
He was applying that knowledge to
his job for sure. He was doing that.
So that's cool.
That's 3.0
what about quality of work?
Another section, quality of work.
Here's a 5.0 for quality of work needs.
No supervision.
Always produces exceptional work.
No rework required maximizes resources,
so need to know resources.
Let's think about that. I mean,
this guy was working
in another department.
He was definitely being managed and
then always produces exceptional work.
Again, this is as good can it
get any better than exceptional?
Hmm.
So I said,
is that you?
Do you not need any supervision?
And he knew. I mean,
I know I worked in the departments. I know
what's going on. He, he's not going to,
you can't lie to me. And I said, how
about this needs little supervision,
produces quality work. Few errors,
uses resources efficiently.
You know what that is?
That's 3.0 hmm.
I actually gave you a 4.0
somewhere in between those two.
I'm actually being kind of generous.
What do you think?
How about military bearing and character
with, let's see what that looks like.
Here's what,
here's what,
here's what the definition for military
bearing and characterised us navy 5.0
evaluation.
Exemplary personal appearance,
model of conduct,
conduct on and off duty.
A leader in physical readiness
exemplifies navy core values.
Honor, courage, commitment. Now,
this guy is sitting in my office,
he's in sloppy PT gear.
His hair's a little bit long and he's not,
he's not one of these superstud seals.
That's an awesome physical shape.
He's kind of a guy that liked to party
a bit and he was a hardworking seal.
A great guy. But I'm saying
he wasn't exactly a model
of conduct on and off duty.
Think about what that means.
A model of conduct.
So that's 5.0 then I said, listen,
let me tell you what I tell them,
but let me tell you what 3.0 is excellent.
Personal appearance, excellent conduct,
conscientiously complies with regulations,
complies with physical readiness program,
lives up to navy core values, honor,
courage, commitment. That that to me,
you know you're a pretty squared away guy,
but how'd you do on that last PT test?
Right? Cause you, you didn't knock it
out of the park. I know that. Right?
So you are you telling him?
Yes, you're reading, reading.
I'm just doing what
we're doing right here.
I'm straight up reading
them to them cause cause
it was really obvious that
these standards are very,
very high.
And you know also here's the
bottom of the barrel. Okay,
this is 1.0 1.04 for values or for
military bearing and character.
This is 1.0 consistently.
Unsatisfactorily appearance,
poor self control conduct
resulting in disciplinary action,
unable to meet one or more physical
readiness requirements fails to live up to
one or more navy core values.
Honor, courage, commitment. So,
so this guy clearly is not a 1.0 that's
a, that's a horse. Know that's a,
that's a bad sailor. But this
guy's solid. He's in the middle.
I think I had him with a four point.
I said Aye. Aye. We good with a foro
or you going to tell me that you crushed
that you were the leader of the pack on
the last PT test that we did.
You know w when you tell me were you the,
were you the 5.0 no.
Couldn't honestly say it.
And by now he kind of,
he kind of got the message that he's
no 1.0 but he definitely wasn't a 5.0
either.
And,
and clearly what I realize is he
never actually read through what those
standards were.
And clearly that was my fault for not
making sure that this guy and the rest of
the people at my command understood
what the grading criteria was.
And I started to try and do that and
I started to realize that the grading
criteria was actually solid and it was a
good guide to being a really good seal,
a really good sailor,
a really good person.
And as you read through
some of these 5.0 qualities,
here's the one for command organizational
climate slash equal opportunity.
So if you're, this is your, if
you're a five oh in this category,
measurably contributes to the navy's,
increased retention and reduced attrition.
Objective,
proactive leader,
exemplary mentor involved in subordinates,
personal development,
leading to professional growth
and sustained commitment,
initiate support programs for military,
civilian and families to
achieve exceptional command
and organizational climate.
The model of achievement develops unit
cohesion by valuing differences as
strengths. So let's think about
that. That's, that's a massive,
who's going to get five? Oh, in that,
in the seal teams, not too many people.
Because in the seal teams who's
initiating support programs means you're
actively starting a program to help
support, right? There's not a lot of guys,
they're going to hit 5.0 and that's
the way it should be. Here's what,
5.0 it looks like for personal
job accomplishment and initiative,
energetic self starter completes tasks
or qualifications early far better than
expected.
So you're not just doing,
you're doing it early and it's still
even better than everyone else.
Plans and prioritizes wisely and with
exceptional foresight seeks extra
responsibility and takes
on the hardest jobs.
That's 5.0 here's the,
here's the five bullet 0.0 for teamwork.
Team builder inspires cooperation
and progress, focuses,
goals and techniques for teams the
best at accepting and offering team
direction. That's a team
player. That's teamwork.
And here's, here's the, here's
how you get a 5.0 in leadership.
Now think about this.
You think you're a good seal,
you think you're a good sailor and you
think I'm, I'm a good leader, right?
Here's what you have to do to get a
5.0 inspiring motivator and trainer.
Subordinates reach highest
level of growth and development.
So now all of a sudden,
not even about you anymore.
It's about you being a leader
and you not just what you do,
but what your subordinates,
your subordinates have to reach the
highest level of growth and development.
It goes on.
Superb organizer.
Great foresight develops process
improvements and efficiencies,
leadership achievements,
Dr. Leadership at treatment,
dramatically further command,
mission and vision.
So what you do as a leader
dramatically furthers the mission.
Okay?
Perseveres through the toughest
challenges and inspires other others.
Exceptional communicator.
How many people did you know that
are exceptional communicators?
There's not a lot of
people that are exceptional
commuters. That's a hard thing.
That's not only being born
with some communication skills,
it's actively working and honing
those skills through your lifetime.
Before someone tells you you're
an exceptional communicator.
Make subordinate safety conscience
maintains top safety record constantly
improves the personal and professional
lives of others. So this is,
this is barely even about you anymore.
It's how well, how well does your team do?
So you've got to be 100% squared away if
you're going to get a 5.0 in leadership.
That's just the way it
is. And, and like I said,
you're not just getting judged on
your success, but on the success,
not just of the mission, but of the actual
individual people that work for you.
And so this,
this granular look at these descriptions
kind of changed this guy's perspective
and it now he actually saw what he was
supposed to be doing and he actually knew
what he was aiming at and
he didn't know that before.
And you know who's fault it is that he
didn't know that it's my fault because
I'm the guy that's in charge and I thought
everyone knew or I thought at least
everyone was aiming as high as
they possibly good at everything.
But that's actually naive.
It's naive for a couple reasons.
Not only is not everyone aiming to
be the best they can, I don't know.
Some people don't care about some things,
but sometimes people don't
actually understand what
it is that they're supposed
to be aiming at.
They don't understand what the metric is,
how they're being measured,
and clearly you have to have something
to aim at and if you don't have anything
to aim at, then you're never going to
get anywhere. You're never going to be,
you're never going to hit the
target that's you're not aiming at.
You have to aim at the target to hit it.
You have to know what you are
trying to be or you won't be that.
And the navy,
I think with this evaluation form
does a decent job. If you kind of can take
a step back and one problems with the,
with the navy evaluation system and all
the evaluation systems in the military
is they're very administrative.
It's,
it turns into more much more of a
paperwork drill than it is an actual,
an actual attempt to make people
improve themselves. Right.
It's there, but people go all go to
FAU. This is where I fell out. Cool.
I'm a promotion called man. They don't
read it. Yeah, right. They don't actually,
it's not,
it's not a true counseling up to the
objective isn't to really truly improve
those people. That's one of the
problems with this, with the,
with the counseling system inside the
navy and it happens in the other branches
as well. But, but if you read that
sheet and you kind of take a look at it,
then you realize, okay, there's
some things that I can aim at now.
And the navy does a decent job of that.
I'll tell you,
the Marine Corps does an even better job.
The United States Corp evaluation
system is more detailed and it's more
descriptive and it's more complete.
The navy system than the whole
navy evaluation is two pages long.
The Marine Corps,
there's is six pages long.
And one thing that's interesting
about the marine corps, you know, in,
in the navy one they list,
okay,
you're a 1.0 this is what you're like
as a 1.0 the marine corps doesn't even
give description for the low end of the
spectrum. They did. They don't even,
they don't even exist.
They're not going to waste
time describing a loser marine.
They have a higher minimum
standard basically. But
this is one thing that struck me the
first time I kind of noticed the Marine
Corp evaluation system cause it's,
it's an administrative thing so it's not
like I would see it on a regular basis.
When I was in Ramadi,
I was in the brigade tactical operation
center and I was probably there for a
meeting with the brigade
commander or whatever and was
there for whatever reason.
And one of the marine officers was in
there who I knew and we were kind of
talking and he was filling out one of
an evaluation for one of his guys and he
was on the back page of his evaluation.
And I was just being nosy I guess looking
at looking at what it was like looking
at what their system was like,
comparing it to our system.
And as I was looking at
the form on the last page,
the page he was actually working on there,
whereas a graphic representation of of
marines and of how they rank marines and
it kind of looked like a Christmas tree.
So if you picture a Christmas tree and
the whole Christmas tree is made up of
Little Eagle Globe and anchor,
which is the symbol of the Marine Corps.
And so there's a bunch of Little Eagle
Globe and anchors and they're all
positioned on this piece of paper
and it looks like a Christmas tree.
And so the, the bottom, the actually
the, the bottom of this graphic,
the bottom of this Christmas tree is just
an empty space. There's nothing there.
And,
and that line is representative.
There's a little indicator that
shows what that line represents.
That line represents
the unqualified marine.
So there should be no
unqualified marines in your unit.
And then it goes up one level and now
you've just got one single Eagle Globe and
anchor representing one
marine. And, and this, this is,
it looks like the trunk of the Christmas
tree and that that line is labeled a
qualified marine. So now you've got
one guy, you know, percentage wise,
one person that is simply
just a qualified marine there.
He's qualified but there's not,
this shouldn't be that many of them.
And then they'd go, now he picked
her Christmas tree above the trunk.
Now it's a big wide area and that's
where they go to this next level,
which has the most,
it's like the middle third
of the Christmas tree and
that area they labeled that
area.
One of the many highly
qualified professionals who
form the majority of this
grade.
So the biggest chunk of people is sort
of in the middle third of this Christmas
tree. And that's what it is.
Hey, that's what most of,
that's where most of the guys are.
There's Holly highly qualified people.
They make up the most of this
group of that that I'm evaluating.
And there they are.
And then above that third
on this Christmas tree is a,
now the Christmas tree is getting smaller,
right?
So now we're getting into a narrow group
in this narrow group is labeled and
it's called Sophie.
You're in this group,
you're being labeled as one of the
few exceptionally qualified marines.
And that again, that's a much smaller
number than that middle group.
And then you get to the top
of the Christmas tree where
there is a single eagle
globe and anchor representing
the very best of this group.
And it's up there alone
at the pinnacle of performance.
And there's a label for this singular
marine at the top of his group.
And the label says the
eminently qualified marine.
And I remember when I read that,
when I read those words,
the eminently qualified marine
and I, I thought to myself,
that is the ultimate praise.
And that's pretty much how the
Marine Corp evaluation ends.
And it ends in this epic way
because it is, it is an I,
I,
it's weird to say this,
it's an epic document. It's
an epic, epic document.
And I want to talk about this document
today and I want to start off by,
by the way,
that the document itself starts off.
So this is the Marine Corps fitness
report. This is how they grade marines.
And it starts off with
the commandant's guidance.
So the first thing they'd get his guidance
from the most senior marine in the
Marine Corps
and the commandant's guidance says the
completed fitness report is the most
important information component
in manpower management.
It is the primary means of evaluating
a marine's performance and is the
commandant's primary tool for the
selection of personnel for promotion,
augmentation, resident schooling,
command and duty assignments. Therefore,
the completion of this report is
one of an officer's most critical
responsibilities inherent in this duty
as the commitment of each reporting
senior and reviewing officer to ensure
the integrity of the system by giving
close attention to accurate
marking and timely reporting.
Every officer serves a role in the
scrupulous maintenance of this evaluation
system. Ultimately important to both
the individual and the Marine Corps.
Inflationary markings only serve to
dilute the actual value of each report.
Reviewing officers will not
concur with inflated reports.
So out of the gate we're
getting put in check.
Do not come here telling everyone
they're great. That's not,
that's not gonna fly where we're
rejecting that outright from the start.
Now we start the evaluation and again
this is set up a little bit similar to the
navy and they start breaking out what
your performance is based on the first
thing that it's based on his mission,
accomplishment
and mission accomplishment.
They break into two things.
The first thing is performance.
So here's what it says about
performance of mission accomplishment,
accomplishment, results achieved
during the reporting period,
how well those duties inherent to a
marine's billet plus all additional duties
formally and informally assigned work
carried out reflects a marine's aptitude,
competence and commitment to the
unit success above personal reward
indicators,
our time and resource management task,
prioritization and tenacity to
achieve positive ends consistently.
So the low end it says meets requirements
of billet and additional duties,
aptitude, commitment and competence.
Meet expectations, results,
maintain status quo so that
as you're doing your job,
okay.
And then if you're at the
high end of the spectrum,
results far surpass expectations,
recognizes and exploits new
resources creates opportunities,
emulated,
sought after as an expert with
influence beyond unit impact,
significant innovative approaches to
problems produce significant gains in
quality and efficiency.
If you just take that single bullet
and that's what you try and achieve,
you're smoking, you're
crushing you. I want to,
you have someone like that working for
you and you're in heaven because this guy
is going to make things happen.
Next up.
Proficiency demonstrates technical
knowledge and practical skill and the
execution of the marines.
Overall duties combines training,
education and experience translates
skills into actions which contribute to
accomplishing tasks and missions
imparts knowledge to others.
Think about this one translates
skills and actions. That's it.
That's kind of a big deal.
How many people have skills,
but they can't translate them in actions?
Thinking about that your life. Hey,
you got some skills, but you don't
use them. You can't put them anywhere.
You can't put them into a fact.
Here's the middle grade for proficiency.
Demonstrates mastery of all required
skills. So if you've mastered your skills,
you're still just like in the
middle. Expertise, education,
and experience consistently
enhance mission, accomplishment,
innovative troubleshooter and problem
solver effectively impart skills to
subordinates.
These are the kinds of things where if
you load that you're supposed to impart
skills to your subordinates. You pay
attention to it, you start doing it,
but you might not recognize
that that's part of your job.
That's part of your life. Here's what
it sounds like if you're an expert.
True expert in field knowledge and
skills impact far beyond those of peers,
translates broad based education and
experience into forward thinking.
Innovative actions make a measurable
impact on mission accomplishment.
Peerless teacher selflessly imparts
expertise to subordinates, peers,
and seniors.
Think about that.
That is a high bar man. That
is a high bar. You could work,
you could work diligently every single
day and fall short of that. Yeah,
but let me tell you,
it's important that you know that you
should be working towards it. Yeah.
Next section.
Individual character.
Isn't it legit? When you're going
to grade someone on their character,
this is outstanding.
This is outstanding.
How many people are not thinking
about what their character is,
how many people are not actively minding
the way that their actions reflect
their character happens all the time.
Oh yeah.
If we were thinking about if you
knew you're getting graded on it,
maybe you wouldn't take those,
those base actions. Yeah. Yeah.
Kind of like goes along with
like how you said that one time,
like imagine someone's videotaping,
you know,
and they're going to do the
playback. It's like, man, if you go,
if you have that in the back
of your mind yet you act.
That's the first step though,
because the actual,
that's the first step because
you might think, well,
I'm being videoed but this
is what I'm expected to do.
So you might be doing
something that's not correct.
You might be off chart. You might
be aiming at the wrong thing. Hey,
I'm acting like a tough
guy. I want everyone to know
that I'm tough. You realize,
oh, that's actually stupid.
Yeah. So you can be,
you can have in your mind that
I'm going to keep my character,
but you're wrong because you might
be aiming at the wrong thing.
So this gives you some pretty
specific things to aim at.
Topic number one,
core courage,
moral or physical strength to overcome
danger, fear, difficulty or anxiety.
Personal acceptance of
responsibility and accountability.
Placing conscience over competing
interests regardless of consequences.
Okay.
Conscious, overriding decision, risk,
bodily harm or death to accomplish
the mission or save others,
the will to persevere despite uncertainty.
What if you're thinking about the fact
that you're getting graded on your will
to persevere despite uncertainty?
You think about that every day.
You don't know what your future holds,
but you're going to persevere regardless.
Think if you're getting
graded on that every day. Hmm.
Here's what the bottom end of the
spectrum is. Demonstrates inner strength.
So at the minimum,
you're demonstrating inner strength
and acceptance of responsibility
commensurate with the scope
of duties and experience,
willing to face moral of physical danger
in pursuit of mission accomplishment.
So even at the low end of the spectrum,
you're still willing to face danger.
Moral or physical challenges.
Here's the middle.
Guided by conscious in all actions,
proven ability, proven ability
to overcome danger, fear,
difficulty or anxiety exhibits bravery
in the face of adversity and certainty,
not deterred by moral
difficult situations,
morally difficult situations
or has miss responsibilities.
How often are people deterred
by difficult situations,
daily, morally, morally
difficult situations?
Here's at the top,
the top of the spectrum for courage,
uncommon bravery and capacity to overcome
obstacles and inspire others in the
face of moral dilemma or life
threatening danger but not.
It's not even just about you.
You have to actually take it to level.
We're inspiring others demonstrated
under the most adverse conditions.
Selfless
always places conscience over competing
interest regardless of physical or
personal consequences.
That's a competition.
We talked about the competition between,
oh,
I'm going to take care of myself and
I'm going to take care of the team.
I'm going to take care of the mission
between what's doing what's right to do
instead of what is easy to do.
The next section that you get graded
on your individual character is
effectiveness under stress.
This is just outstanding because there's
not thinking about this and you don't
even see this in in business.
I don't see this and when people
evaluate other in the business world,
but there is stress in business
world is a different kind of stress,
but it's stress. Here's effectiveness
under stress. Here's what you're doing.
Thinking,
functioning and leading effectively under
conditions of physical and or mental
pressure.
Maintaining composure appropriate for
the situation while displaying steady
purpose of action,
enabling one to inspire others while
continuing to lead under adverse
conditions.
Physical and emotional strength.
Resilience and endurance are elements.
Low End of the spectrum. Exhibits
discipline and stability under pressure,
judgment and effective problem
solving skills are evident.
Just the low end of the spectrum. By
the way, how many people do you think,
do you know that don't exhibit
any discipline or stability
under pressure, right?
There's all kinds of people.
Yeah,
there's all kinds of people and we
know when's the last time you you,
you didn't do a good job under pressure?
Probably this morning.
It happens, right? Fully write comments,
especially when you're
not thinking about it,
especially when you're not aimed at
the correct response to pressure. Yeah.
Especially when you haven't
put a standard in your mind.
Remember when you used to kind of
freak out in Jujitsu when you got
claustrophobic, right? Sure.
Yeah. Right? Sure. You get,
you'd get in a position. Yes, sir.
Yeah. Usually side control. Right.
You didn't like that. The pressure on
the neck, the pressure on the chest.
There were more circumstances
surrounding those, you know, scenario.
Does she has a mental and moral problems?
Yeah, it would have to. Yeah. Okay. Yes,
I do remember that. At some point
you said to yourself, all right,
I cannot act that way
anymore. Yeah. You made a,
you set a bar for yourself.
Yes, sir. That's the beginning
of solving the problem.
That's what I love about this.
It's actually setting a bar
of when you're under stress,
this is how you got to act if you're,
if you're a little above average
for effectiveness under stress,
here's where you're at.
Consistently demonstrates maturity,
mental agility and willpower
during periods of adversity
provides order to chaos
through the application of intuition,
problem solving skills and leadership.
Composure reassures other,
imagine you are on a team
and this is the average guy.
This is just so impressive.
But my point is unless you
tell your guys what average is,
they won't know it. Yeah,
they don't understand it.
Here's the high end. So this is when
you look at your troops and you say,
this is what I want you to do. When we
come under massive amounts of stress.
Here's the model I want you to
try and perform as demonstrates.
Sell the matched presence of mind
under the most demanding circumstances
stabilizes any situation through the
resolute and timely application of
direction, focus and
personal presence. Now,
what I was doing this,
I was actually only gonna read the high
end when I was thinking about this,
but then I realized each one of these
built and that person at the high end
already has the other two.
But there's other elements in there
that aren't mentioned in the high end.
So you've got to mention me and you
assume when someone's on the high end,
they got those. Obviously they got the
lower end things wrapped up, right?
So you got to combine all these
three together, the low grade,
the middle grade in the high grade.
We want people to show initiative.
Talk about this all the time.
This is the essence of decentralized
command, is that people show initiative.
Here's what they say about initiative
action in the absence of specific
direction,
seeing what needs to be done and
acting without prompting. Hmm.
So I'm listening to all, all of these,
this whole thing. And at first I was like,
oh,
that's cool.
That's how the navy kind of evaluate
the people and sure you're going to talk
about the marines and stuff,
but maybe like the second
little part you started reading,
I just started applying it to myself.
That's what I'm saying, like my life.
Okay. So you know, we're, we're all part
of that. Like, if you have a family,
if you're at the dad or something,
right, or your whatever, if you,
if you're in a family unit,
you're part of a team right there.
And you know your goals change from time
to time, but you sorta know the goals.
So I'm like thinking in my mind every
little like element that you're talking
about, I'm like, okay, let me
evaluate myself for sure with this.
Like how good and you're right, man. So a
lot of times, a lot of times like, okay,
so performing under under stress,
right?
Like there's all these little things.
You're going to the beach and
you're trying to make it on
the house and make it the beach.
We have a high stress level.
The kids need their water and
they need their change of clothes.
It might get cold,
they need to Jackie and all this stuff.
Meanwhile the clock is
ticking, you know, daylight.
You could go on and miss
sunset, all the stuff. Um,
so how are you going to perform under
that stress? You know, and I get it.
The funny thing is you're, you're
bringing up this, you're bringing up this,
and I'm actually completely making fun
of you for bringing up that stress.
How often are you at a public place and
you see a family and they're running
late or whatever,
and you see a leader of the family,
mother or father freaking out and losing
their composure over the stress that we
were actually joking about. Yeah, you're
a little bit serious. I'm joking about it.
But still you see people lose
their minds because of dumb things.
Oh yeah.
And it,
there's a little bit of stress in
their world and they dropped the ball.
They freak out. Farm. Exactly. So
my question is, do those people,
has anyone ever sat them down and explain
to them what the standard is? Yes sir.
And that's my point here. Yeah. A lot
of times people don't even recognize,
they don't even know.
They don't even understand what,
what the eminently qualified human being,
how they are going to act in these
situations. Yeah. It totally, totally,
exactly 100% right there. So like, okay,
so you know how he ever have a guy who
like loses his temper and then like you
say,
hey,
you kind of lost it there and then he
goes back to how he felt like almost like
the way he felt justified. Right. So you
just understand, here's the thing Brad,
we know you felt like that.
You totally demonstrates.
So you don't have to explain
that. But yeah, you were feeling
this and you behaved a certain way.
But if that guy knew that he was
being evaluated on his behavior,
regardless of how he feels, but he, he'd
be aiming how you put and that's it.
It's not, it's not just the
grading part. Yes, it's,
you have to know what the standard is
because that guy that might not even
understand, hey, if I lose my
temper, it's, I think it was either,
I think it was JP.
Jp really took it to heart when he
heard me say losing your temper is a
weakness. The for that.
He just didn't, you know,
because you see other people in
your life and see other team guys,
you see your dad,
you see your uncle and they fly off the
handle and you almost have a respect for
it, right? You definitely respect your,
when your dad loses your temporary,
you kind of think, wow, that's powerful.
How can I have some of that power?
While you just do that,
it's a learned mechanism.
And then eventually you realize
or someone tells you, Hey,
when you lose your temper, you're
not in control. And matter of fact,
you're not controlling all and whatever
made you lose your temper is controlling
you. And losing your
temper is, is a weakness.
And so that's the big difference. It's
not just, hey, you're being graded,
you're being watched, which is
definitely a great mindset to have,
but you have to understand
what the parameters are that
you're being measured by,
that you're being graded on.
And that's where this comes into play.
The next section,
I'd just started with initiative
and we want subordinates
to take initiative,
but we want everyone to take
initiative, right? Or your kids.
You want your kids to take initiative.
You want people in your, if you want to,
everyone to take initiative.
I used to say to the young seal platoon
commanders and tasking your cleaners,
I would say imagine if everyone of your,
everyone,
your fire team leaders just
was doing something smart.
They just took initiative
and made it happen.
Your job becomes so easy because you
don't have to control everything.
Everyone's just making things happen.
That's initiative.
So here's what it says about initiative
action in the absence of specific
direction,
seeing what needs to be done and acting
without prompting the instinct to begin
a task and follow through
energetically on one's own accord,
being creative, proactive, and decisive,
transforming opportunity into action.
So that's what initiatives,
if you're on the low end,
you demonstrate willingness to take action
in the absence of absence of specific
direction, acts commensurate with
grade training and experience.
That's what we expect of you. Little
bit, little bit better in the middle,
self motivated,
an action oriented
foresight and energy consistently
transform opportunity into action.
Develops and pursues creative
initiative solutions or sorry,
innovative solutions acts
without prompting. Self
starter. That's what we want.
And then here we go.
The high end,
highly motivated and proactive displays,
exceptional awareness of
surroundings and environment.
Uncanny ability to anticipate mission
requirements and quickly formulate
original far reaching solutions
always takes decisive, effective
action with definitions like that,
it's no wonder there's only been one
marina at the top of that Christmas tree
because that is a squared away
individual right there. Far region.
Know what's crazy about this?
Having put so many people
through training myself,
even though there's only
one allotted space up there,
there are so many people that are
capable of this kind of behavior.
It's way more than 1% it's way more than
10% if you have people that understand
what the parameters are
and really aim towards,
you can get a lot closer than most
people would think. Yeah, and I,
I mean I obviously, I don't
know, but it seems like what you,
what you're talking about, if they,
like a lot of people just don't know
the standard and the, you know, they
don't know. Yeah, they don't know.
It's not been made clear to them.
The next section,
leadership, and this is broken
into multiple sections obviously,
because leadership is the most
important thing on the battlefield.
So this is their biggest section.
Leadership section number one,
leading subordinates.
The inseparable relationship
between leader and lead,
the application of leadership principles
to provide direction and motivate
subordinates using authority,
persuasion and personality to influence
subordinates to accomplish assigned
tasks,
sustaining motivation and morale while
maximizing subordinates performance.
So there you go. That's what you're
going to do as a leader. Low End
engaged provides instructions and directs.
Execution seeks to accomplish mission in
ways that sustain motivation and morale
actions contribute to unit effectiveness.
Cool. So you're acceptable. Yeah.
Middle Ground.
Okay.
Achieves a highly effective balance
between direction and delegation.
We're talking a little dichotomy.
Effectively.
Task subordinates and clearly
delineates extent. Standards,
expected enhances performance
through constructive supervision,
fosters motivation,
enhances morale,
builds and sustains teams that
successfully meet mission requirements,
encourages initiative and
candor among subordinates.
So you can see that the,
the low end,
you're kind of just telling people
what to do a little bit right.
Hmm.
Now you're starting to ask for feedback.
You're starting to build that bond.
Here's the high end
number one thing for the high end
promotes creativity and energy among
subordinates by striking it.
The ideal balance of direction and
delegation achieves highest of performance
from subordinates by encouraging
individual initiative.
That's decentralized command.
I'm going to let you guys run and
that's going to maximize performance.
This is an incredible term in genders,
willing subordination,
loyalty and trust that allows
subordinates to overcome their perceived
limitations.
Willing subordination when your
team actually wants to follow you.
Personal leadership fosters highest
level of motivation and morale,
ensuring mission accomplishment even
in the most difficult circumstances.
Next section, developing
subordinates, commitment to train,
educate and challenge all marines
regardless of race, religion,
ethnic background or gender mentorship,
cultivating professional and PR and
personal development of subordinates,
developing team players in a spree decor,
ability to combine teaching and coaching,
creating an atmosphere,
tolerant of mistakes in the
course of learning. You'll hear,
you'll think about that very
often in the marine corps. Hey,
we're tolerant of mistakes.
That's how you learn.
Low End of the spectrum maintains
an environment that allows personal
professional development and sure his
subordinates participate in all mandated
development programs.
Ground develops an institutes,
innovative programs.
It's you're proactively trying to
bring up and raise your subordinates,
make them better to include PMA,
which is professional military
education that emphasize personal and
professional development
of subordinates challenges,
subordinates to exceed
their perceived potential,
thereby enhancing unit morale
and effectiveness creates
an environment where all
marines are competent to learn
through trial and error as a mentor.
Prepare subordinates for increased
responsibility and duties.
By the way, this is the number
two item under leadership.
The first one is leading, the second
one is developing your subordinates.
Here's the top end of the spectrum.
Widely recognized and
emulated as a teacher,
coach and leader.
Any marine would desire to serve with
this marine because they know they will
grow personally and professionally.
Subordinate and unit performance far
surpasses expected results due to
mentorship and team building talents.
Attitude toward subordinate
development is infectious,
extending beyond the
unit that that's bold.
Now you are training your people so well
that other people in other units are
starting to train their people.
Think about that impact right there.
That's how you develop.
You develop your subordinates so much
that some other leader in a different
company,
in a different platoon,
in a different battalion says we're
going to start following that program.
Going to start it up. Yeah,
that's leadership right there.
Section number three is setting the
example the most visible facet of
leadership. How well a marine serves
as a role model for all others.
Personal action demonstrates the highest
standards of conduct, ethical behavior,
fitness and appearance bearing demeanor
and self discipline are elements.
Low end
maintains Marie corn
standards for appearance,
weight and uniform where sustains required
level of physical fitness and ears to
the tenants of the Marine Corps.
Values fine. You're accepted.
Middle-Grade personal conduct on and
off duty reflects highest marine core
standards of integrity
bearing and appearance.
Character is exceptional.
Actively seek self improvement
in wide ranging areas.
Dedication to duty and professional
example. Encourage others.
Self improvement efforts.
That's the middle grade them.
In the middle grade,
you reflect the highest marine
core standards of integrity
bearing in appearance.
You know what that means? That means
24 hours a day you're in the game.
That's what that means.
It means you're active,
actively seeking self improvement
in wide ranging areas.
You're trying to get better everywhere.
That's middle ground by the way.
High Ground
Model Marine frequently
emulated exemplary conduct.
Behavior and actions are tones.
Setting an inspiration to subordinates,
peers and seniors.
Remarkable dedication to
improving self and others.
What are you trying to do to get better?
For me,
as I say that said that on this podcast
since day one we're trying to get better.
What are you doing actually?
Yeah. What's, what's the activity?
Because if you knew another word you see
here a lot and this is action, action,
action words into action, ideas
and actions. Skills into action.
Hmm.
I was going back and forth with
a guy that I did some work with,
four echelon front,
and I worked with him quite
a few years ago overseas,
and we still text back and
forth from time to time, and
he, I said, hey, because he was telling
me some of the notes he had taken it.
I said, send me some of the notes.
One of the notes that he's from,
the first note he sent me was,
you can't think things better.
No, it's, it's,
it's a solid piece of advice because
he's one of these guys that that was a
thinker, right? Yeah. The big thinker, and
I'm all about thinking, you know, let's,
let's develop our brain.
Let's develop our mind power.
Let's think about things. Let's
be thoughtful. That's fine,
but you can't think things better.
They're not going to get better
unless you actually apply the skills,
skills into action.
Fobts into action.
Next,
ensuring wellbeing of subordinates.
The genuine interest in the wellbeing
of marines enhances subordinates ability
to concentrate.
Focus on mission accomplishment.
Concern for family readiness is inherent.
The importance placed on welfare of
subordinates is based on the belief that
marines take care of their own
low end of the spectrum deals confidently
with issues pertinent to subordinate
welfare and recognize a suitable courses
of action that supports subordinates.
Wellbeing applies available resources,
allowing subordinates to effectively
concentrate on the mission. At a minimum,
you're absolutely taken
care of your people.
Middle grade instills and or reinforces
a sense of responsibility among junior
marines for themselves and
their subordinates actively
fosters the development
of and uses support system search for
subordinates which improved their ability
to contribute to unit mission
accomplishment efforts
to enhance subordinate
welfare, improve the units ability
to accomplish their mission.
People don't think about that fact
that the people that are actually
accomplishing the mission,
our people,
and if those people aren't ready to
perform because you've neglected them,
you're not going to be to
accomplish the mission.
High grade noticeably enhances
subordinates wellbeing,
resulting in measurable
increase in unit effectiveness,
maximizes unit and base resources to
provide subordinates with the best support
available.
Proactive approach serves to energize
unit members to take care of their own,
thereby correcting potential problems
before they can hinder subordinates
effectiveness.
Widely recognized for techniques and
policies that produce results and build
morale, builds strong family
atmosphere, puts motto,
mission first,
Marines always into action.
Boom.
Last section for leadership
communication skills,
the efficient transmission and receipt
of thoughts and ideas that enable and
enhance leadership. Equal importance
given to listening, speaking,
writing and critical reading skills.
Interactive,
allowing one to perceive
problems and situations.
Provide concise guidance and expects
xpress complex ideas in a form easily
understood by
allows subordinates to ask questions,
raise issues and concerns and venture
opinions contributes to a leader's ability
to motivate as well as council.
Minimum
skilled and receiving and conveying
information communicates effectively in
performance of duties.
That's the minimum
above average middle grade.
Clearly articulate thoughts and
ideas verbally and in writing.
Let's think about that
middle ground.
Do you know how hard it is for people
to clearly articulate faults and ideas
verbally and in writing?
It is a skill you need
to work on all the time.
By the way.
This gets you a middle grade here.
Communication in all forms is accurate,
intelligent,
concise and timely.
Those standards accurate,
intelligent, concise and timely
communicates with clarity and verve.
Ensuring understanding of intent or
purpose encourages and considers the
contributions of others
high grade.
Here we go.
Highly developed facility
in verbal communication,
adept in composing written documents of
the highest quality combines presence
and verbal skills which indent in gender
confidence and achieve understanding
irrespective of setting situation
or size of group addressed displays.
An intuitive sense of
when and how to listen,
so,
okay,
read, write, speak, listen
and do it all the time.
If you're in a leadership
position or you want to be in one.
Okay.
The the reading part,
people ask me what I learned in college.
One of the most important things that I
learned in college was I was an English
major. This is why I was an
English major by the way,
because I recognized when
I was at a seal team,
as a young officer that one of the
most important things I was going to be
dealing with was communicating
with other humans.
And I needed to have good command of
the English language and of reading and
writing the English language.
But when I had to decipher Shakespeare
and I took a lot of Shakespeare and you
realize that you don't know what words
mean and you realize that you don't
understand the sentence
construction and you,
what you realize is that you have to
break them down and go them and figure it
out.
So when I would get the
rules of engagement from up
the chain of command five
years later,
and I didn't understand them because they
were using words I didn't know, I said,
okay, what I needed to do
is look these up, read it,
find out some substitute words,
make sense of it,
look up the definition of what they're
specifically talking about and go from
there.
Because when you first,
if you just open up Shakespeare
and you don't understand something,
what do you do?
You say it's stupid.
When somebody writes a rules of engagement
and there's words in there you don't
understand.
If you don't understand how to parse
things apart and look up definitions and
can't be humble enough to recognize that
there's some things that you don't know
well then all you do is
go all this is stupid.
Check communications.
The next thing,
no one really probably thinks that this
is going to be in here for the Marine
Corps. The next section you're getting
graded on as graded on as a marine.
His intellect and wisdom.
Yeah,
thanks to people in the military
is a bunch of knuckle draggers.
Think it's all about brand,
but there you go.
Intellect and wisdom, intellect
and wisdom, professional,
military education.
PME,
committed to intellectual growth in
ways beneficial to the Marine Corps.
Increases breadth and depth of war
fighting and leadership aptitude.
Resources include residents,
schools,
professional qualifications
and certification processes,
nonresident and other extension courses.
Civilian educational
institutional coursework.
A personal reading program that includes
but is not limited to selections from
the commandant's reading list,
participation in discussion groups and
military societies and involvement in
learning through new technologies.
Okay,
you got to get in the game, right?
They're going to get educated.
Here's low end maintains currency and
required military skills and related
developments has completed or is enrolled.
Inappropriate level of PME for
grade and level of experience.
Recognizes and understands new and
creative approaches to service issues.
Remains abreast of contemporary
concepts and issues.
Yeah.
Middle-Grade PME outlook expense expands
beyond Mos and required education.
So you're not even worry about your
own job. You've got that covered.
Now you're going outside
of what your job is,
develops and follows a comprehensive
personal program which includes broadened
professional reading and
or academic coursework,
advances new concepts and ideas.
And here's your high end dedicated to
lifelong learning as a result of active
and continuous efforts,
widely recognized as an intellectual
leader in professionally related topics,
makes time for study and takes
advantage of all resources and programs,
introduces new and creative
approaches to service issues,
engages in a broad spectrum
of forums and dialogues.
So this is never going to stop.
You've got to keep feeding your brain.
The next thing you're getting graded on.
Intellect and wisdom, decision making,
ability, viable and
timely problems, solution,
contributing elements.
Our judgment and decisiveness decisions
reflect the balance between an optimal
solution and a satisfactory workable
solution that generates tempo.
So there's a good dichotomy for you.
Optimal decision on on one side,
workable decision that can keep
you moving. On the other side,
you've got to balance that dichotomy.
Decisions are made within the context
of the commanders established intent and
the goal of mission accomplishment.
So of course you're trying to support
the commander's intent. Anticipation,
mental agility,
intuition and success are inherent.
This is not the first time they
brought up intuition in here.
How you develop into intuition,
experience, wisdom, breeding,
low end,
low end makes sound decisions leading to
mission accomplishment as the minimum.
The minimum was to make sound decisions
actively collects and evaluates
information that ways alternative
alternatives to achieve timely results,
confidently approaches problems,
accepts responsibility for outcomes.
Middle-Grade demonstrates mental agility.
Okay,
effectively prioritizes and
solves multiple complex problems.
This prioritize and execute
analytical abilities enhanced by
experience, education, and intuition,
anticipates problems and into
implements viable longterm solutions,
solutions, steadfast, willing
to make difficult decisions.
That's a, that's a high bar
for middle grade, high grade,
widely recognized and sought after
to resolve the most critical,
complex problems.
Seldom matched analytical
and intuitive abilities.
Accurately foresees unexpected problems
and arrives at wealthtime decisions
despite fog and friction,
completely confident approach to all
problems masterfully strikes a balance
between the desire for perfect
knowledge and greater tempo,
widely recognized
to solve problems.
This one though,
this little line here,
accurately foresees unexpected problems
and arrives at wealthtime decisions
despite fog and friction as a big ask
right there, you gotta be in the game,
you gotta be in the game
to get to that level.
Last thing you're getting great on, on
for intellect and wisdom, his judgment,
the discretionary aspect of decision
making draws and core values,
knowledge and personal
experience to make wise choices.
Okay.
Comprehends the consequences of
contemplated courses of action.
Okay.
Minimum Grade Majority of judgments
are measured, circumspect,
relevant and correct.
Minimum middle-grade
decisions are constant,
our scar consistent and uniformly correct.
Tempered by consideration of their
consequences. Able to identify, isolate,
and assess relevant factors in
the decision making process.
Opinion sought by others,
subordinates personally,
personal interest in
favor of impartiality.
Okay.
And the high end decisions
reflect exceptional,
exceptional insight and wisdom.
Beyond this marine's experience,
counsel sought by all often an arbiter
consistent superior judgement inspires
the confidence of seniors.
So that's how you get graded
on intellect and wisdom.
And actually the last thing that they
grade you on is they actually grade you on
how well you evaluate your other marines.
The extent to which this officer serving
as a reported official conducted or
required others to conduct accurate
uninflated and timely evaluations.
This is the last thing you get great
at all and they go through and you're,
the low end is like you did a good job.
The high end is you do an outstanding job,
but they're grading you on how well you
grade. And then you get to the last page,
which is where this is where
you have the Christmas tree,
the Eagle Globe and anchor Christmas
tree comparative assessment provide a
comparative assessment of potential by
placing an x in the appropriate box in
marking the comparison,
consider all the marines have this grade
whose professional abilities are known
to you personally.
And then you go through that tree,
the unqualified on satisfactory,
a qualified marine,
one of the many highly
qualified professionals who
formed the majority of this
grade, one of the few
exceptionally qualified marines.
And then you get to the top,
the singular marine at the top who
is the eminently qualified marine,
the eminently qualified marine.
And
that's what I think makes this,
makes this interesting,
is to to consider that
statement imminently qualified
and think about where you're at
and you're, you're not at
the top. I'm out of the top.
None of us are at the top who can be,
but what are we striving to be?
What are we striving to be?
Are we striving to be the most eminently
qualified human being that we can be?
Do you even know what that means?
Do you even have those
thoughts in your head?
I'm guessing you don't.
I barely do.
I know I've had vague thoughts.
I know I had definitions that floated
around in my head of what I was trying to
be,
what I'm trying to be today,
but why aren't those solid?
Why aren't they?
I was, I was thinking about this. I was
talking to Dave Burke deal Tafe. Yeah,
good deal, Dave. And I was like,
Hey, we need to build this.
You're basically an
evaluation system for humans
to become eminently qualified as a human.
What does that look like?
Not only to graved yourself,
but to actually know what
you are trying to be.
So Dave and I will work on that.
So stand by to get some
and until,
until we do get that out,
then think about,
think about are there areas that,
you know
what the goal is that you're walking
around thinking that you deserve a 5.0
but you really actually,
he really actually deserve to.
I know I do that. Yes.
Right? I'm thinking I'm good.
I'm walking around. I'm thinking I'm
running everything right. I'm thinking,
I'm thinking I'd come correct.
Yes. But the reality is
I don't, you know, and,
and the reality is that you have that
little moving goalpost in your head.
You move it around a little bit,
right?
You give yourself a little
bit more slack one day,
then you tighten it up cause
you're feeling good the next day,
then you slack it off a little bit more.
But I think as far as you're concerned,
that's a five. Oh, right.
You're there. You're in there.
And the reality is,
I don't measure up the way I should
be measuring up on a daily basis.
Yeah.
On an hourly basis.
Who's grading me?
Who's lagging to me? You
know, who is me? Yeah.
Yeah,
me.
But until we clarify what the aim is,
what the goal is and
what those standards are,
how am I supposed to hold
myself accountable to those
standards when they don't
even exist? So I'm going to make them
exist. Yeah. I'm going to put them in.
I'm going to put them on paper.
We're going to come up with that
eminently qualified human being.
What that looks like because we all got
all got ideas floating around up there.
Yeah.
Well I'm going to bring it, bring it. I'm
going to apply that. Put it into action.
Put it into action. Right. Are we doing
everything that we could be doing?
Everything that we should be doing? Are
we cutting corners? Are we slacking off?
We'd given ourselves a 5.0 when we
should be at best. Cracking a too
daily. How much are we leaving
on the table every day?
That's a question for you,
right? How much are we leaving
on the table? How much you
say, Nah, you know what?
I can just leave that
there. It's fine. How much?
How many things just do you
accept this collateral damage?
Like something goes wrong,
like one thing goes wrong and so
there's just collateral damage.
Other things are just gonna fall by
the way. And you're good with it. Yeah,
you're good with it.
You, you, you know you,
I hurt my knee. Oh, cool. Guess
what? I'm gonna eat a donut, right?
Is that where we're at?
Is that where we're at or is there
collateral damage? Oh, work was hard.
Therefore I'm going to know,
treat my family, not going to,
not going to have good
family quality time tonight.
Collateral damage because they what
to expect from me. Yeah. Right?
Where's the collateral damage? Why are
we allowing this collateral damage will,
part of the reason I'm telling you that
we allow this collateral damage just
cause we're not effectively grading
ourselves. And even worse than that,
we don't even know what standard
we're trying to achieve.
No one's even told us the
minimum standard. Okay,
so why is your life going marginal
right now? Why are you doing okay?
Why am I doing okay right now? Well, it's
because I have some vague idea. I have, I,
I kind of know I'm heading in
the right general direction.
That's not good enough to get
maximum.
It's not good enough to be eminently
qualified. It does. It doesn't work.
You have to step it up.
Okay.
You have to,
you have to have the unmitigated daily
discipline in all things and that's hard.
It's hard for one day.
Never mind every single day.
So I'm going to make this evaluation.
Dave and I are going to make it.
I'll get it out to y'all and until then,
and I'll try and get it turned
around as quick as possible.
At least some kind of a,
okay.
What is it called? An early version. A
Beta test? Is that what it's called? Uh,
sure. I think, no, the
technology. Right, right, right,
right. Yeah, sure. Beta test.
We'll get a Beta test.
We're trying to get something out there
quick and until then start looking at
yourself as usual, your
strengths, your weaknesses,
and start trying to see
where you can improve.
Okay.
Start moving towards the goal of becoming
the eminently qualified human beings
where we're heading.
And I think that is all
I've got for tonight.
So Echo Charles, what do you got? Well
I got, I know, I know. We're trying
to step up. Yup. We got thoughts.
Well yeah. So you, and you
actually mentioned it in
like bright there at the end.
There were all these Little
Eva oh that little bit.
All these evaluations are like,
you know,
you do this consistently
and all this stuff.
It's so there's two kind of parts
to that one. I was thinking you,
you have to do all these good things,
right? To be the minimum or to be the,
you know, you, you can't even really be
in the group if you're not in the minimum.
Right.
But you got to do those things every day.
Like you have to essentially be
known for these things. Yeah. So,
so how we get jammed up,
I think when we do,
when we are conscious of like how good
am I doing in Xyz area of my life or
whatever, and if it's something
that you're working on,
a lot of times we don't get the accurate
evaluation to ourselves because we'll
do, we'll do it really good one day
and we'll do a really good two days.
And I'm like, Dang, I'm
pretty good at this,
so I'm going to go ahead and get
myself for like a four or whatever.
But meanwhile you only did
it twice, meaning, you know,
in the whole week you did it twice.
You're so happy because it's this big
change because you usually do it zero
times. Yeah. So you're
like, hey, I got this.
Your minimum bar was set so low that
you think you're crushing it. Oh yeah.
Oh yeah.
Good Times a near miss because in your
mind you kind of are comparatively
speaking, heritable thing. Is it like
if you have a standard and stuff,
then you can act more accurately,
but we don't have standard.
So in your mind it feels like, oh, I
got this, I got it licked. I'm, I'm,
I'm a four now. You know, I used
to be a one, I'm a fort now.
So meanwhile you're not a
four year actually still a
one. Yeah. Really, really?
Yeah.
You think you're, you're,
and there's also, there's
also this, there's also an a,
and I, I talked to Dave about
this a little bit. There's a,
there's a short term grade and there's a
longterm grade, because check this out.
Let's say you,
let's say you've never worked out before
and you've been watching video games
and eating donuts and,
and just, you know, in,
in bad physical shape. Yeah. Your grade,
your overall grade for
physical fitness is whatever.
It's a 1.0 it's a low,
it's the lowest it can go.
But daily if you get up, okay, look, look,
I can only run one mile and it's going
to take me 20 minutes, 22 minutes,
I'm going to do it. And then I'm
going to do as many pushups as I can,
which is 23.
By the way,
if I did a one mile run in 22 minutes
and did 23 pushups, that would,
I would get a 1.0 for the day. Yeah. But
this individual that's been on the couch,
the living a sedentary lifestyle,
if he does that, guess what?
He's going to get him.
He's going to get a high grades
going to get a 4.8 for the day. Hmm.
So then he's leaving himself
in the right direction. Yeah.
So not only is that, not only do you have
to, this is one of the problems in it.
And again, this is something I told
Dave, I'm like, listen, uh, once,
uh,
by annual twice a year,
every six months you're getting
a grade that doesn't help you.
What you need to look
at yourself every day.
You need to look at
yourself every day and say,
did I truly do live this way,
live the way I should be living today?
Yeah.
And then those standards need to be
clear and then you need to apply them to
your life.
Yeah.
I might even say like the, the, the,
that that example you just gave.
So the guy who was sitting on the couch
all the time whenever or every day and
now he's doing it.
He's working out every day,
but his physical fitness standard
technically is still low.
Still be at a 1.0 maybe another
area of evaluation is like,
you know, improvement or are you know to
say or back when you're young, you know,
they give you that most
improved kind of thing. Yeah.
Maybe that could be part of it. I think
it will be covered by the daily track,
the daily track, like, okay,
you got to, you got a 4.0 today.
What's your average right now?
My average for the last,
my running average for 30 days is
I'm hitting a 3.9 physical fitness.
That means I'm doing something every day.
I'm pushing the envelope, I'm improving.
Now my overall score is moved
from a one to a 1.2 yeah.
Cause I'm,
I'm in a little bit better shape,
but it's still not where it needs to be.
But guess what?
That can crush them people.
Right?
If someone goes to a 1.2 I'm
never going to improve it.
So it's been three months. No guess what
would you get today? What'd you do today?
Same thing. Opposite, right? The opposite
can happen where someone thinks, well,
I did something, I did something
today, so I'm good man. No, no.
And the other collateral damages,
I did good physical fitness today,
so I'm going to take tomorrow off or I'm
going to eat a, you know, a crappy meal.
Yeah. We get that pizza together.
Right? We don't want that. We,
and when I say we, I mean me.
Yeah. In that, why is that?
Because we've, we've,
we've created this, this,
this pliable standard in our head that
we move around based on our little
feelings. You, but, but this does,
this won't allow for it.
You need to keep yourself in check.
You need to keep yourself
in check at all times.
And the reason you need to keep your
check self in check at all times,
you need to impose discipline on your
life because you will end up in a better
situation that you will end
up in a better situation.
You'll end up with more freedom is where
you're gonna end up. You know, people,
you talk about regret, right? Oh,
you go talk to people when they're,
when they're dying on their
death bed and they're,
they're going to regret
things they didn't do.
There's nothing I can imagine you're
going to regret more than when you look
back at your life. And you said, and I
didn't achieve what I could have achieved.
Yeah. And there's only one way
to maximize your achievement.
And that's to get daily discipline,
daily discipline. And again,
when we're talking about achievement,
what are we talking about?
I'm not just talking about I worked more
than you. I made more money than you.
I produced more, I sold more cars and
that's not what I'm talking about.
I'm talking about what, what is
your, what is your achievement? Yeah.
What is it you're trying to do?
I spent a bunch of time with my
family and raised great kids. Okay.
That's what you want to do. Put that on
paper so you know what that looks like.
Maybe there is a financial there.
It should be a financial aspect
to it because you need to pay,
you need to have a roof over your head.
You need to be able to feed your kids.
So you certainly should have a job of
vocation aspect to grading yourself.
Are you doing what you
should be doing that work?
Because if you're working hard at work,
guess what?
You're going to get promoted eventually.
Are you going to find it?
You're going to improve your skills to a
point where you're be more valuable and
you can go find a different
job somewhere else.
So that's gotta be in there because if
what we allow ourselves to do is show up
at work every day and just do what
we need to do to get by. Guess what?
You're never leaving that job.
You'd be doing that thing forever.
So it's physical fitness.
It's what you're eating,
your fuel systems that you're putting
into your body. It's the family,
the the,
the effort.
What are you doing to improve
the skill sets of your children?
What are you doing?
What are you doing to improve
the skill sets of your children?
Are you spending 20 minutes teaching them
new vocabulary words so that they can
articulate better so they can become
a better leader when they get older?
Are you doing that?
Is that a big ask as a dad,
as a mom,
are you doing,
have you showed them how
to escape a Dia Tiene?
Have you? Maybe you should because
you can get caught. Negi team.
That's the street fight right
street by gay teens are coming.
So have you,
does your kid know how to escape
of Guillotine in a street fight?
How much is it? How long will it
take? You got to teach him today.
That takes 15 minutes,
but you've got to drill it.
Got To drill it every day until
they kind of understand it.
So what have you invested
in your kids today?
What's the minimum standard now you
could think to yourself, well, you know,
I got my kid an iPad for Christmas.
That was an awesome gift.
So I'm pretty much good to go as a dad.
Right?
Does your kid care about
that iPad compared to,
are you fast forward three years where
your kid's got an incredible vocabulary
and can defend gay teens?
Right?
So how much have you
invested in your family?
Yeah,
so these are the kinds of things that we
can set a moving goalpost where you can
set a moving goalpost
that says, I buy, Hey,
if you get your kid an iPad with
some apps on it, you're a good dad.
That's a moving goalpost.
Hey, you should, hey,
if you can get your kid an iPad and
they can get some educational stuff,
you feel pretty good about
it. Cool. Good job. Is that a
moving goalpost? Yes, it is.
Because what they really need to
know is have a better vocabulary.
What they really need is interaction with
you as a human being so that they can
interact with other human beings in a,
in a more complete way.
That's what we're doing. So you got
your physical, you got your okay mental,
what are you,
how much have you read today?
And I'm not talking about reading
somebody's freaking Instagram post.
That doesn't count.
Get negative credit for that.
You're getting dumber when you do
that. Yeah. So what, what do you,
what are you doing? How many words
did you learn today? And by the way,
this is brain maintenance too. Cause if
you're not trying to learn new things,
then your brain is deteriorating
just like your body will.
So you've got that aspect.
What about your creative output?
What have you done in that capacity? Did
you write us? Did you draw a picture?
Did you write a story? Did you come up
with a guitar riff that kind of rocks,
right? Did you, cause
you may or may not have.
My guess is you didn't.
So how,
what have you done that today?
And where, and by the way,
if you think,
oh,
I took a cool picture for Instagram
and I'm kind of giving myself artistic
credit for output right there. No, no.
So,
and then you start looking at all this
stuff and you start adding it together.
Your time that you've invested in your
work and your family and your friends,
and you're trying to try to teach your
kids something and you're trying to read
something and all of a sudden you look
and you say, well, I don't have much time.
And then you look at yourself and say,
wait a second, why? Where did my time go,
Dick? What grade do I get today
for time management? Yeah.
It's a big one because did I spend time
doing things that I got negative value?
Nevermind break even
actually negative value.
Yeah.
And we don't have a grading system.
We don't know what we're aiming at.
We don't know what the potential is
because that's what's cool about this.
And you, you read these definitions,
the high end, the outstanding,
the eminently qualified.
That is an unachievable human.
Yeah. It's an unachievable
marine. You will not be that good.
You cannot hold all those categories.
But let me tell you something that is no
reason to not aspire to become the most
eminently qualified human being that
you can become just because it's an
impossible path.
Just because it's a
path with no end to it.
Just because you'll never reach the
top of the mountain ever. You will not.
You cannot.
Guess what that is.
No reason to stop. Guess what? Jujitsu,
you're going to get tapped out. You're,
there's always going to be someone
that that can tap you out always.
100% of the time, the best guys
in the world get tapped out. Yeah.
The best guys in the world get tapped
out. Boot Chechnya, Hodra Gracie,
which touches the best guy in the world.
What happens?
He goes in GE and loses to Gracie.
Tapped out. Submitted. Why
is that? Because somebody is
always, and what happened?
Roger Gracie, by the way, when he
fought Tim Kennedy, he got beat down.
So there's always, you're never going
to get to the top of the mountain,
but that is not theirs.
That is not a reason to,
not to stop climbing.
Just because you're not going to reach
the top of the mountain doesn't mean you
stop climbing. No, actually you climb
Harger you see where you can get,
but if you don't know
what you're climbing,
if you don't understand the mountain,
if you can't see the summit,
you don't know where to climb.
And then you just look around and gone,
well I might as well just slide
down because it, it, it, it's,
it takes physical and mental
exertion to move up the mountain.
And if I don't even know where the top is,
I'm just going to,
I can't tell where I am. I can't tell
him from them halfway up the mountain,
the quarter with the mountain, I can't
tell from close to the top, bottom,
top and can't tell.
So there's enough reason for me
just to sit around and do nothing.
Break out the donuts,
not the,
okay. So the way you
started this was, was, um,
with your navy experience as far
as evaluations go and it, okay.
So this is essentially what it would,
it kind of translated to
me what it was in the navy.
The one that you were talking about was
like everyone expected to get the, the,
the perfect score. Right. And that was
sort of the standard. And then the,
in the Marine Corps one, it's
kind of the opposite. Well No,
the navy ones started on
when I first got in the navy,
basically everyone was a 4.0 and then
they changed it because you need to force
rank. And I dunno when the Marine Corps
or if they made that change, but it,
but they did because that's the way it
is now. They're forced ranked for sure.
Okay.
So the,
and the point is just the
two different standards,
like common like standards,
right. You know, when,
cause you get this in other
places too where it's like,
oh, you know, it's just, uh,
just your, here's your quarterly
evaluation and I just put force, you know,
cause I don't have any complaints
about you kind of thing.
It doesn't necessarily reflect how
dope you really are. It's just,
I don't horny how dope you could be. Yes,
exactly right. So it's just more of like,
okay,
so the ceiling is pretty low is what it
is by like a common like perception as
far as the standard goes. Then you gotta
have the opposite where it's like, oh,
we all know no one's going to get a five.
Like we all just know that. So we're,
we're just kind of doing the
best we can kind of thing.
And in that way is better up for obvious
reasons. But at the end of the day,
it's like when you say,
Oh yeah,
you can literally be like you're topping
out because as you get better and
better, it's harder to get
better and better. Yes. So if,
but you won't even get
to those upper levels.
If that ceiling was so low and you're
ripping four is all day, they're all year,
whatever. Man. I used to, um, he used
to play his game. Super Mario brothers.
You ever heard of that supermarket?
I've ever played one single second
of that particular video game.
All right. Dang Bell. Okay.
I played halo one time for about three
minutes with some of the guys that was in
my seal platoon.
And then I just think it
was after thought it was a,
they were really good at it. They
murdered me a bunch of different ways.
Then I said, well, this is
stupid. It's a video game.
I don't care who wants to go
grapple. Yeah, well that part is,
I would say that that's true, but this
the, the point still is consistent.
So Super Mario brothers. It's
okay. See, it's Super Mario.
There's a bunch of Mario brothers.
This one is, this is more,
this one is called Super Mario brothers
original Nintendo entertainment system
here. I don't want to
say 1,904 old school.
So Super Mario Brothers had four
worlds, uh, sorry, eight worlds,
four levels each world.
So 32 levels.
And you have an opportunity at various
points in some levels to hit the warp,
like the warp zone. So He'd go down a
pipe in, it skips like all these levels,
right? So you could see, you
could essentially get through
the game in maybe like,
I don't know, six or eight
levels. Okay. If you worked right,
but if you chose not to work, you
would have to go through all 32 levels.
So I used to be able to
go through all 32 levels,
never dying one single time. Like
I got really, really good at that.
You're for those either just listening
and not seeing this on video echo looks
super proud of that last statement.
I mean I was a little bit embarrassed
for him, but it's cool anyway. Okay,
32 levels.
Here's why.
Here's why that's significant though
as far as Super Mario brothers goes,
because you can easily pass the game,
save the princess by just
warping and it's still real hard.
But you, you gotta, you know,
you only go through a few levels compared
to if you go through all the levels
voluntarily, right? So once you
save the princess by working,
it's like cool, now you've got
to go through all the levels.
But if you can do that without dying,
that's like that's super high level,
right?
As far as Super Mario brothers goes. So
it's basically, so what's your points?
So go to this two standards,
go back to the two standards.
If you go for the stand it's like oh yeah,
everyone gets a kind
of a 4.0 kind of thing.
That's like passing the passing of the
game by warping. It's true. Like man,
you passed the game in one man.
Damn that's good.
That's good by any standard really.
You know I can't complain about that.
But you've got to open up the standard
little bit more go through all 32 levels,
men without dying. Then you do it
as quick as you can kind of thing.
And if that standard kind
of allows for all that,
where you can't reach
the top a little bit,
like the standard isn't saving the
princess standard is like something way
greater.
You see what I'm saying?
So it allows you to get better
and be evaluated on that,
on that elevation while still not
like capping out at a certain level.
You see what I'm saying?
Switch.
You got to do as far as the evaluation
process goes. Okay Bro. I'm telling you,
I'm telling you, look to Supermarine
there's this thing they discovered.
He was like a glitch in the game where
you could like go to this one level and
do this thing with a turtle shell and
keep jumping on it and get like a thousand
men, which is kind of a
step backwards in a way.
But that's just a side note
day.
Okay. How much time have you
spent playing video games? Well,
and what you could've done with your life.
Yeah.
Well keep in mind that guitar
you could have played, you know,
instruments could have mastered chess.
You could have spoken another language
instead of you're over here talking about
how you did 32 levels in one
minute. By the way, this is it.
This gets you a really low grade.
We'll come up with a system.
Your grade is going to be the low. Yes. As
far as achievements goes, yes, very low.
But as far as an evaluation process, did
all that translated highly respect you?
I did g Charles go dang
man. Did He Kinda, yeah,
sometimes there you go with it.
That you finally got that respect too.
You want and from that side,
Mario Bros in fifth grade by the way.
So you know a little bit different.
Was that a humble brag?
Like I did 32 levels by the way.
I saw me in fifth grade. No,
I think it was more of
an aging thing actually.
That wasn't a break at all because in
fifth grade you could have been learning
the language. Yes sir. Yeah, we're
doing pull ups were actually,
it was doing pull ups in fifth
grade. That's legit. Yeah. Big Time.
I thought the check. Well,
okay, here's the bottom line.
We are looking to step up.
We are looking at to,
to become better,
truly better. So what do
you got for us? How can you,
how can you help us get better?
Yeah. To stay in the past. So,
and actually that brings up a good
point because we're on the path,
quote unquote right,
you whatever,
all on the path and saying we're even
saying we're on the past straight up
saying, but like what is the path though?
I mean, sure, there's some things,
you know, we can go through it and
you did too of course as part of it,
but you don't have any evaluation kind
of standard is what you say it. So yeah,
I think that'll be how actually I'm
really looking forward to it to be honest
with you. Yeah. And the last digit. So
yes, that's on the path. Here's the, okay,
so this will help us prep then.
At the very least,
prepare to be officially on the
path and be evaluated the same time.
Get jiggy, right. Step one kitty Geek.
Step one,
be get a rash guard.
So where do we get our gies and get her
keys from origin or [inaudible] dot com
best cheese in the world. Factually.
Actually the new rift is an hour.
So let's just live re this is like when
you put it Rifkey on and then go back to
your old geezers. Like I said
this before, this is a nonstarter.
You're going to be mad at your old gay,
you're going to be Trey, your old g.
You're going to wonder why anyone ever
made a ghee like they used to make them,
but then again, then you're
going to, then if you choose,
you can revisit or you can visit that
video that Pete put out about like,
you know, made and like all
this stuff. It's like, oh, okay.
That's why they didn't make it because
what they went through to make it. Yeah.
You know, not, not everyone's
[inaudible] as usual,
we are standing on the shoulders of
giants because you always look at the way
things have evolved and you have
to take those iterative steps.
No one just thinks of
the iPhone,
right?
Somebody had to make a bunch of other
phones before that and then even consider
iPhone like right now. Like what is the
newest one? I dunno, x or something.
Something. 10 x is the tent
and you know, Roman numerals.
I guess I didn't know that at first.
Anyway,
the one in six years from now is going
to make this x ten one you'd be like,
oh, it's the old school. You know,
like not unevolved neanderthal one.
That's what going to feel like.
That's what your old g will feel like.
Yes.
A Non Neanderthal Geeky and you
put it on the rift. Oh yeah.
So you should get done. You can get
the gies, you can get the rash guards,
she can get other clothing do.
You can also get supplements,
which right now I am taking a ton of
joint warfare. Yeah, I hurt my knee,
which is not that big of a deal cause
let's face it, I'm walking around,
you know we're going to be fine.
It's not that big of a deal.
I don't want people to feel like,
oh no, what happened? Don't worry.
Everything is fine.
I did however up the joint warfare
and continue the Krill oil path,
but the g the joint warfare,
you can feel it in there,
can feel it like little micro nano
robots in there repairing stuff.
Now you have to, you know, I know
what happened with your Bicep,
but the last time I hurt my
other knee it was a disaster.
And this one is already.
So you guys get your joint warfare.
I remember you. Well, I mean,
of course I remember it because it was
as recent as today where you're like
around like Wolverine. But I'm like, yeah,
well I dig it.
It's probably the joint warfare but
has to, something to do with it.
But also there's some,
there's definitely,
I definitely have been blessed
with some sort of uh, ability to,
to heal up a little quicker.
Thank thankfully, knock on wood,
that's what it seems like to me.
Well also we have moke which is additional
protein that happens to be delicious
and taste like a dessert straight up.
It's the way it goes with that also.
Where are you kidding? Mock. Same deal
just for the kids in the same deal,
but they have strawberry or your kid milk,
which is literally the best tasting
thing in the world. Yeah. Uh,
that has strawberry flavor cause men
is still my favorite and we do have
strawberry adult milk coming out.
It need that and it is ridiculous.
What is t and d test and evaluate.
Oh,
so I got the little package in
the mail and it was so good.
So yeah, you can get that.
You know, also discipline
and discipline go.
So discipline if you are going to train
Jujitsu or you're going to do something
that's going to require physical output
and at the same time mental alertness.
So that's,
for me it was always about hey pre mission
cause it when you're on a mission you
have to be physically ready and
you have to be mentally ready.
You need a both aspects.
And so that's why we made disciplines
or you're ready for those things.
And then also we have discipline go,
which is a,
which is a capsule.
And the reason I made this is because
sometimes I'm going to speak or I'm going
to work with a company or I'm going to
be in a board room all day and I want to
bring my a game.
Sure.
And I don't want to have to drink a whole
beverage because I don't don't need it
at that time. So I talked
to Pete, Brian, we took the,
the elements from discipline drink,
put them into the capsule is that
way if you need to bring your a game,
you can get your discipline go and that
will get you across the board and some
will a little bit of Jocko white
tea look good in the original,
the original tea that Jellco was into.
Yeah,
just kind of a white tea. It's you
know, at first but not sort of a stable,
it's like synonymous, you know
Jocko white tea. Yeah. It's just,
it's synonymous with good taste.
It's synonymous with 800 pound deadlift.
So there's that big time.
Also the t is available at Jocko
store cause yes Jocko has a store,
which we already know but that's a good
place to visit to stay in the game to
represent while you're in the game.
So if you want t shirts,
we got some lightweight hoodies rolling,
rocking and rolling.
A lot of good evaluations.
No comment.
Yeah cause you haven't put one on
yet because you haven't given me one.
Well you know, let's face it,
you kind of deserved that one.
And it's also changing minds of people
who were originally weren't really assign
special forces over here.
Psyops you know what? Hey,
the truth be told they
came out really good.
Just even like the fit the design cat
on the other night. Yes. There it is.
One of them. There's two for
this too. Okay. That's right.
You can get truckers hats. Yup.
Patches on their watch or other stuff.
Yeah, a bunch of cool. Sorry. Yeah.
If you want to duck store.com if you want
to represent while you're on the path
while you're being evaluated, that
might even be one of the evaluation, uh,
scenarios. Your uniform. Come on
anyway. I guess if someone's
just a complete Slob, yeah.
Then maybe they do need to step
it up. Somebody. Yeah. Okay.
Maybe uniform will be judged,
but I doubt it. Well, okay.
Well what be wearing a stinky
geezer though. Oh yeah, no, that's,
that's a uniform violation.
Big Time. Yes sir. Oh,
you didn't want to wash your g so now
we all have to suffer. Yeah. Yeah.
You're going to get punished.
What of don't do that. Hey,
the Rifkey the cool thing you can
watch with your normal clothes. Yeah,
because it's, and it'll
dry. It's just not,
it's not like when you put a regular g
in and it's like you threw a 40 pound
weight washing receipt and go, go,
go, go, go, go, go, go, go, go.
Yeah. Yeah cause it all bunch of, that's
all. And it takes nine hours to dry.
Not the rift. A rift drives with your
normal like quick dry tee shirts.
Just about, did you see the video Pete
head when he's like going into the fibers?
Like he takes care of one fiber and it's
like breaking in and it's hard to break.
He puts the two and you can't even
break it. The whole g is that, yeah,
it's good man. Real good. Oh,
so subscribe to the podcast
if you haven't already.
That is for black of a better term.
It's important.
It's something,
it's not nothing like to subscribe
versus if you didn't subscribe,
don't forget about also
the warrior kid podcast.
So this is one where your
kids can actually be educated.
This is quality time with your kids.
You sit there and listen to where he
could podcast instead of driving your car
and you're playing some lame music for
them or you're having them listen to some
dumb podcasts. No. Have him
listen to warrior kid podcasts.
They're going to learn from it. You're
going to learn from it. Just check it out.
It'll, it'll help. It will help your kids.
I just got a text this morning
from a buddy who said he had a,
this is going into the book,
but he had a nephew who had been
through a rough time and 10 years old,
got in the warrior kid book, Boom
Warrior kid who he's like, Hey,
there's that book completely changed the
trajectory of my nephew's life and it
doesn't get much better than that,
but the warrior kicked podcasts has
the same messages in a podcast format.
So check that out. And also while you're
there, you can check out some of that.
Irish oaks ranch.com where we have
a warrior kid that is making soap,
started a business making soap on his
farm from goat milk and that goat milk
will help you stay clean and clean. My
daughter has a question for oncologists.
Oh, okay, cool. I'll send it to him.
He said the double take, you know,
we'll get that sorted. Might also
youtube. We have a youtube channel.
If you're interested in the video
version of this podcast to see what Jocko
looks like. Well he, you know, gives
it to you straight. That's, you know,
that's where you go.
There's also some of echoes legit videos
on there that he calls legit videos.
He feels good about it, feels really
good about them and just like,
he feels good about
guiding through 32 levels.
Uh, yeah. Kind of. Yeah. Sometimes I
think we've got psychological warfare.
If you need a little, everyone
that looks for an alarm that says,
oh really be great to have an alarm,
but chuck, we'll make an alarm.
That's the alarm. Psychological warfare.
It's on iTunes, Google play MP3 platforms.
And not only will it wake
you up in the morning,
but if you're having a moment of
weakness because you want to eat a donut,
this will 100% effective. Stop you
from eating a donut. Press play,
psychological warfare. Check it
out. Also flip side canvases.
My brother Dakota Meyer,
you heard him on this podcast number one
15 if you haven't listened that podcast,
just go listen to it.
Give yourself about four hours
cause it's long and it's heavy,
but he's got a company where he's putting
images on to various forms of canvas
of nylon or what does it,
vinyl,
vinyl and you can take these things and
that way these are kinds of things you
can put up in your house where you look
at it and you get that little extra
message to go get some or that all your
excuses are lies or that things are good
or that discipline equals freedom.
So check it out. Flip side,
canvas.com support my brother,
Dakota Meyer.
Some really good stuff on there.
Also we are looking to expand your,
your workout horizons.
Go to [inaudible] dot com slash Jocko
they got some good workout gear on there,
a lot of good info, a lot of
good stuff on there. Overall,
it's like to to optimize
your whole situation,
but yet really good stuff on there on
[inaudible] dot com slash shop some books
I just talked about way the warrior kid,
that's a one that's
book one the next book,
it's same series called Mark's mission
and then there's the third book in the
series, which is called way the
warrior kid where there's a will.
So that is now live for preorder
at this time. If you want it,
order it now.
That way I can print enough copies for
everyone that's called the big preordered
that I used to make fun of my publisher.
But guess who the publisher is now me,
so I have to know how many to print.
So if you want it,
order it now and it's going to
come out May 28th so there you go.
Also,
we have Mikey and the dragons.
This is a book to help kids
figure out how to overcome fear.
Sure your kids could lead.
Read some book where you could read some
book to your little kid that's about
things that don't matter in the world.
Or You could read them a book that helps
them actually learn how to overcome
their fears. That's Mikey and the
dragons. Great Story. Awesome art.
Very awesome. Yes. The discipline
equals freedom field manual.
Give the gift of discipline.
That's, that's all there is to say.
It's the book that's going
to show people that you,
it's going to show people the path.
If you want that on audio form,
then that's not on audible.
It's on iTunes, Amazon music,
Google play and other MP three platforms.
Then you've got extreme ownership,
which I wrote with my brother Leif Babin
where we took the leadership lessons we
learned on the battlefield and explain
how those can be applied to your business
and life,
and one of those lessons in that book
is called the dichotomy of leadership.
The dichotomy of leadership seem to be,
as we continue to work with businesses,
companies,
leaders around the world,
we found that the biggest problem that
they had was balancing the dichotomy of
leadership and when you can't
balance the dichotomy of leadership,
the multiple dichotomies of leadership,
when you can't balance them,
they derail your whole team.
So get extreme ownership and get yourself
the dichotomy of leadership so that
you can understand how to truly apply
these things effectively. Echelon Front,
that's my leadership consultancy and
what we do is solve problems through
leadership. We have an outstanding
team of outstanding guys,
Leif Babin, JP Denelle, Dave Burke,
Mike Cochran or sorry, Flint Cochran,
Mike Cirelli, Mike by Emma,
and now Jason Gardner.
If you need help at your company with any
problem because every problem that you
have in your business is a leadership
problem. That's what we do.
We solve problems through
leadership echelon front.com
we have the muster coming
up,
Chicago 23rd and 24th we haven't
pulled the sold out switch yet,
but we're going to, it's almost sold
out September 19th and 20th that's,
that's May 23rd and 24th in Chicago,
September 19th and 20th in Denver and
then December 4th and fifth and Sydney
extreme ownership.com
if you want to register,
do it quickly because all of them
are going to sell out eff online.
This is for those that can't make it to
a muster or you can't bring your whole
company to a muster because it's
expensive. That's why we made e f online.
This is online interactive
leadership training.
It's me and it's everyone on
the echelon front team training,
leadership through technology.
It's,
it's available direct to consumer.
If you're just one person you want to
get in the game or you've got a company
and you can get it through enterprise,
but if you want to check it out,
go to e f online.com and of course on
top of that we have e f Overwatch where
we're taking
leaders,
proven leaders from SPEC ops and
from combat aviation, putting them,
placing them into companies
in the civilian sector.
Don't always hire someone based just
because they have experienced in a field,
actually hire them for their leadership
capability because it is a lot easier to
teach someone an industry than it
is to teach someone leadership.
So get yourself a qualified,
proven leader.
Go to F,
overwatch.com if that's what you need
and if you want to hang out with us a
little bit more because you're just not
satisfied with 500 hours of us on this
podcast. Well then we are on the
interwebs, we are on Twitter,
we are on Instagram and
of course we are on dad.
They see walk de Boer Echo is that Echo
Charles and I am at jockowillink and
thanks to all the people that
make this podcast possible.
And by that I mean not
some big corporate sponsor.
By that I mean our police,
our military,
our law enforcement, our firefighters,
paramedics, EMT dispatchers,
correctional officer's border
patrol and yes, secret service.
All you first responders,
all you in uniform,
your service and your
sacrifice allow us to live,
to live a life of liberty
and the pursuit of happiness,
which is what we're doing here.
And everyone else out there,
check yourself,
evaluate yourself honestly,
are you doing what you
can do to be better,
pretty working as hard as you can and
that just doesn't mean work as in your
vocation or your job.
Are you working to be a better
father or mother or daughter or son?
Argue, maximizing
opportunities. And again,
not just professional opportunities,
but opportunities to help someone,
to teach someone, to coach someone
to make someone else better.
Yeah.
Are you maximizing the opportunities
to spend time with your family to
strengthen the relationships you have?
Are you maximizing the opportunities too?
Make the members of your family better?
Yeah.
Are you every day doing everything you
can to live the most eminent we worthy
life you can live.
Ask yourself those questions
and when you realize that you fall short,
that we all fall short.
When you realize that,
then get yourself on the path to correct
those shortfalls by going out there
and getting after it.
And until next time,
this is echo and Jocko.
Okay.